[Applaudissements]
en commission vous avez discuté amender
et adopter la quatrième partie du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale
depuis hier l'examen du texte se tient
en sciences publiques et je souhaite
remercier ici toutes celles et tous ceux
qui ont permis la débat la tenue d'un
débat riche dense et constructif
[Applaudissements]
cependant aujourd'hui
1160 amendements restent à examiner
au rythme où vont les travaux nous
aurions donc encore besoin de plus de 80
heures de débat pour achever l'examen du
texte or nous arrivons au terme du
calendrier que vous avez établi pour sa
discussion par ailleurs demain commence
l'examen de la seconde partie du projet
de loi de finance et je rappelle que la
discussion de ces deux textes est
encadré par des délais fixés par la
Constitution
en outre tous les groupes d'opposition
nous avaient fait savoir qu'il ne
voteraient pas le texte final malgré
l'adoption du projet de loi en
commission et la qualité des discussions
en séance aucun président ne nous a
indiqué que la position de son groupe
avait évolué nous avons besoin d'un
budget de la Sécurité sociale
nombre des mesures de ce projet de loi
sont attendus par les Français aussi sur
le fondement de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la Constitution j'engage la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement sur
la quatrième partie et sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale
le texte que je vous soumets ce soir a
été profondément modifiée et amélioré
il tient compte de vos échanges en
commission et il reprend la
quasi-totalité des amendements adoptés
en séance
[Applaudissements]
au total plus de 150 amendements ont été
retenus des propositions de la majorité
comme des oppositions et je veux
également saluer les travaux
transpartisans menés sous l'égide de la
rapporteur général le texte est donc
considérablement enrichi et ce ne sont
pas que des mots grâce à vous le nouveau
texte compte de nombreux avancées des
avancées pour les personnes âgées en
perte d'autonomie avec un meilleur
financement des services à domicile ou
encore l'accroissement des contrôles des
EHPAD des avancées pour la lutte contre
les déserts médicaux avec le
renforcement de la permanence des soins
et un meilleur partage des tâches entre
les professionnels de santé
des avancées pour une meilleure prise en
charge des enfants en situation de
polyhandicap des avancées et je sais que
c'était attendu pour la prise en charge
à 100% des prothèses capillaires pour
les femmes atteintes de cancer
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
trouve regrettables que les bancs de la
nuit pêche se soient vidés par
anticipation alors que je cite des
mesures souhaité voulu réclamer parfois
depuis longtemps par la gauche de cette
assemblée
mesdames et messieurs les députés le
débat parlementaire pourra se poursuivre
au Sénat puis en nouvelle lecture et
nous continuerons à agir au service du
progrès social au service des Français
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la première minute
l'Assemblée nationale prend acte de
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement conformément au disposition
de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution le texte sur lequel la
première ministre engage la
responsabilité du gouvernement sera
insérée en annexe au compte-rendu de la
pressante séance en application de
l'article 155 il n'y a premier du
règlement le débat sur ce texte est
immédiatement suspendu ce texte sera
considéré comme adopté sauf si une
motion de censure déposée avant demain à
23h41 et voter dans les conditions
prévues à l'article 49 de la
Constitution dans l'hypothèse ou une
motion de censure serait déposée la
Conférence des Présidents fixera la date
et les modalités de sa discussion
prochaine séance demain à 9 heures sur
la seconde partie du projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 avec la mission
justice la séance est levée